chez m6 heureux de vous accueillir ce
1 qui verra sortir de trosième déjà jeu
après plusieurs mois de travail ce
projet qui est au coeur parce dans sa
phase active puisque je crois les
travaux débuteront au mois de décembre
prochain et l'inauguration devrait se
faire en 2000 cndd qui est programmé
sur cet emplacement se sont bientôt 48
enfants et jeunes en grande partie des
fratries confié principalement par
l'aide sociale à l'enfance de la vienne
qui seront accueillis dans un ensemble
pavillonnaire composé de huit maisons
pour enfants et adolescents une grande
maison destinée aux activités communes
je remercie à ce titre monsieur matrice
de bach architectes futur village qui a
mis son talent à concevoir ni de
l'univers le plus agréable possible le
temps que l'efficace pour les enfants
déjà que nous accueillerons ici
rencontrent des difficultés familiales
d'origines variées
passagère le durable souvent sévères
notre métier notre mission notre savoir
faire c'est de les essayer de leur
redonner des repères dans la stabilité
éducative en maintenant les liens
fraternels tant que cela est il possible
ces enfants sont accompagnés sur le mode
d'accueil continu
les images on fonctionne un peu comme
une aciérie
jours et demi
et générera une trentaine 30 à 43 euros
mais dans un environnement économique
incertain
il faut aussi saluer le courage du
conseil général de la vienne de son
président de toutes ses instances pour
faire le choix de l'avenir posé comme
principe d'action l'attention il s'agit
des enfants en danger et s'engager
résolument pour améliorer leur prise en
charge c'est une initiative qui mérite
d'être souligné
je suis heureux de voir saluer cette
étape symbolique avant de quitter dans
quelques semaines la présidence de la
fondation
je revends occupé par endel mon
successeur monsieur le comte qui porte
une reste le pen en la
journée à nos côtés il aura l'honneur je
pense que présidait la cérémonie
d'inauguration de luxe eps soyez assurés
que nous ferons tous nos efforts pour
répondre à vos exigences
j'en veux d'ailleurs pour preuve un
incident qui s'est traduit cela n'ôtera
directeur général c'est présent que vous
voulez pas comme
dans un moment d'égarement s'est trompé
de train à gare montparnasse mais elle
va monter dans le train plutôt dans le
24 décembre du fort heureusement avant
juste avant la clôture des portes à
trouver leurs actifs j'en sais rien je
fais ça vous prouve la capacité
aussi aux remerciements formulés par ce
directeur général vous avez plus à 3,6
la rapidité d'action et souhaite au
village d'enfants de monts-sur-guesnes
une naissance en en compte puis une
belle et longue vie